censeurs qui est prévu pour les
handicapés qui actuellement en service
un ascenseur destiné aux handicapés en
panne 4 3 lettres pour 250 élèves dont
certaines mal éclairé certains outils
pédagogiques ne sont également pas
fonctionnel le marché par exemple
réservé à la filière vente où les élèves
sont censés écouler les produits est
fermé nous manque déjà un personnel pour
pouvoir gérer donc le petit marché donc
hors de la période des élèves et il
manque également donc tout ce qui est au
niveau de l'exploitation également tout
ce qui est produits s'ajoute au manque
d'équipement des problèmes de sécurité
le lycée installés sur une surface de
quatre hectares concentrent trop d'
espaces ouverts criantes aussi un
sentiment d'insécurité
n'importe qui peut s'introduire dans le
lycée d'accord parce qu'il ya des
ouvertures
là ça débouche effectivement sur un
terrain vague et en plus sur la route
directement sur la route
donc on a plein de petits trous comme ça
tu kaeppelin d'ouverture comme ça tout
petit autour du dc au bout de trois
semaines de mobilisation ponctuée
d'appels restée sans réponse
les professeurs du lycée ce sont ce
matin adressé à la presse
ce que nous savons nous constatons nos
professeurs c'est que nous n'avons pas
le minimum c'est à dire que nous sommes
obligés pour faire noté p
nono qu'aux professionnels d'acheter
nous mêmes les matériaux nécessaires à
la réalisation de cet ep pas de plateau
sportif pas de cuisine pédagogique c'est
un véritable cri d'alarmé que lance les
trente deux professeurs du dc le manque
de moyens la conséquence d'une
trésorerie en berne aujourd'hui la
trésorerie de l'établissement est
tellement faible que j'en arrive à ne
payer que les salaires des personnels
sur le budget d'établissement et donc à
faire patienter mais fournisseurs au
bout d'un moment je ne peux même plus
commander d'autres prestations puisque
je ne suis pas en mesure de pouvoir
honorer mes dettes
donc on temporise c'est douloureux
ça impacte directement la pédagogie d'où
la nécessité aujourd'hui de me redonner
un ballon d'oxygène pour fonctionner
normalement
les budgets alloués pour le
fonctionnement du lycée vont dans un
compte de trésorerie unique dont dépend
également un centre de formation une
exploitation agricole toutes deux
déficitaires chargée des affaires
scolaires à la ctm sylvia 7 soutane
actuellement hors du département
ferme le budget du lycée n'est
absolument pas déficitaire l'argent est
donné pour le lycée c1 et doit servir à
tout ce qui concerne les activités du
lycée je comprends monsieur le proviseur
qui a du personnel à payer et il fait
donc une enveloppe globale lissée cfppa
sauf que nous avons demandé nous à la
ctn de faire un budget préparé entre le
lycée et la ferté à 460 mille euros par
an durant trois ans seraient nécessaires
pour équilibrer les comptes
en attendant le lycée agricole du robert
qui semble être l'ultime chance d'un
public parfois au bord de la rupture
sociale vit sa troisième semaine de
mobilisation